adding her name to the list of accusers
of inappropriate behavior with them by
Donald Trump is a former Fox News anchor
named Juliet huddy
who says that Donald Trump tried to kiss
her on the lips Juliet huh D I think she
moved from Fox News national to a local
Fox News station some years ago and I
don't even know if she's still on a
local Fox affiliate but in any case at
one point she was a relatively prominent
anchor on the Fox News national channel
and she says that she was in an elevator
with Donald Trump in 2005 or 2006 and
that he tried to kiss her on the lips
when they were in the elevator she says
she didn't feel threatened but was sort
of surprised by the entire thing a quote
from Fox News anchor Juliet huh D reads
that quote he took me for a lunch at
Trump Tower just us two she said on
compound media's morning with Bill
Schultz he said good goodbye to me in an
elevator while his security guy was
there rather than kissed me on the cheek
he leaned in to kiss me on the lips I
wasn't defended I was kind of like oh my
god now I've matured and I think I would
say whoa no but at the time I was
younger and I was a little shocked I
thought maybe he didn't mean to do it
but I was kind of making excuses she
eventually left Fox after making a
sexual harassment claim against Bill
O'Reilly which interestingly at the time
Donald Trump said he didn't believe
Juliet huh DS claim of sexual assault
against Bill O'Reilly take that for
whatever it's worth at this point given
Bill O'Reilly's resignation and shame
from Fox News for serial sexual assault
of women and the truth is that this is
just as bad as an allegation as what
ultimately led to Al Franken's
resignation but we know that the right
isn't going to react to this in the same
way that the left does and we know that
because they elected Donald Trump right
that's the proof and also not that it
matters big picture at this point who
knows what's going on in Donald Trump's
current marriage but Julia honey says
that this happened in oh five or OSA
Trump married his current wife and
current First Lady Melania Trump in
January of 2005 which effectively means
that unless this happened on New Year's
Day to Juliet huh D Trump was also
married when this took place not really
a major part of the story the real story
here I'm sure you would agree with me is
that Hillary Clinton sexually assaulted
a pizza boy at comet ping-pong while
personally murdering Seth rich and
Robert Moeller refuses to look into it
I've not actually heard that said by
anybody on the right yet but there are
definitely some recesses of the Internet
in fact there's a popular one on reddit
where you might hear something that
outrageous but anyway Trump was a
Democrat at the time he did this so no
no need to check it out alternate
universe alternate universe that we are
living in right now a truly bizarre time
to be alive and my growing question
everyday is in 25 years
how will the history books and history
teachers and history classes teach what
it is that's taking place right now
that's a growing question that I have
give us a like on Facebook facebook.com
slash David Pakman show we'll take a
break a lot more news breaking over the
weekend and we'll talk about it coming
up